Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at the surprisingly
recent time when boys wore pink, girls wore
blue and both wore dresses.
Gender identification by color began in the
early 20th century in the Western world.
Before this, pink and blue did not hold any
gender specific connotations and there are
numerous examples of men wearing pink outfits
and girls wearing blue; one French author,
Xavier de Maistre (mait-r)in his work, A Journey
Around My Room published in 1794, even recommended
that men choose to paint their rooms pink
and white to improve the mood.
Fast-forward to the early 20th century and
this began to change.
When it did, starting just before the 1920s,
pink was deemed by many guides to be more
appropriate for boys and blue for girls, although
this wasn't even remotely as popular as the
"pink is for girls, blue is for boys" association
that exists today; many people completely
ignored the gender recommendations altogether.
One of the earliest references to this original
color scheme appeared in a June of 1918 edition
of the trade publication Earnshaw’s Infants’
Department,
“The generally accepted rule is pink for
the boys, and blue for the girls.
The reason is that pink , being a more decided
and stronger color, is more suitable for the
boy, while blue, which is more delicate and
dainty, is prettier for the girl.”
In 1927, Time magazine printed a chart highlighting
gender-appropriate colors for girls and boys
according to leading U.S. retailers.
Filene's (in Boston), Best & Co. (in New York
City), Halle's (in Cleveland), and Marshall
Field (in Chicago) all advised parents to
dress boys in pink and girls in blue.
Why did they care at all?
It is generally thought it was simply because
if parents followed such a color scheme, they
would have to buy a whole new wardrobe and
set of baby accessories in the "appropriate"
colors if they had a boy and a girl at some
point, rather than just going with reusing
the one set for both as before.
For reasons unknown, this all started to change
around the 1940s when clothing manufacturers
decided on pink for girls and blue for boys.
It has been suggested that boys simply like
blue more and girls like pink more, but studies
to date trying to see if this is true have
come up with mixed results, except firmly
showing that the vast majority of humans prefer
blue to pink, and pink is actually one of
the adult world's least favorite colors.
(Although as you might imagine, it's difficult
to perform large scale studies to determine
if boys and girls are naturally predisposed
to one color or another without the introduction
of existing learned color biases, even in
countries that don't popularly follow the
pink-girl/blue-boy scheme.)
Whatever the case, the women's liberation
movement of the 1960s and 1970s saw a resurgence
of more unisex or perceived gender-neutral
clothing colors.
In fact, in the 1970s, the Sears and Roebuck
catalog even went two full years without showing
any toddler wearing pink, in stark contrast
to a couple decades before.
But these gender neutral efforts were undermined
with advancements in prenatal testing where
parents could find out the gender of their
baby before needing to buy clothes and accessories.
Once again, manufacturers and retailers started
pushing hard for the "pink for girls" and
"blue for boys" phenomenon that continues
to be entrenched in our society today.
So what did people do before this color association?
Prior to the invention of cheap chemical dyes
that allowed clothes to be washed in hot water
over and over again with minimal fading, most
infants were simply dressed in white for everyday
life and sometimes in random colors for more
formal occasions, with no one color being
favored for boys or girls.
Regardless of color, in both cases, they wore
dresses.
Why white dresses?
White was easy to bleach and, at least in
the beginning, changing diapers is much easier
in dresses than pants.
Further, with children growing rapidly, dresses
were a bit more practical in terms of not
needing to get the sizing as precise.
Even beyond the diaper stage, which was discarded
much earlier back then, gender differences
were not highlighted until children were much
older.
In fact, it wasn't at all uncommon to have
both boys and girls wear dresses or short
skirts until age five or six.
In the early 20th century, as noted, this
began to change.
Beyond the introduction of more colors and
loose guidelines about which color went with
which, boys started wearing garb associated
with men at a younger and younger age, resulting
in a shift away from dresses and a move towards
pants.
A similar significant shift happened during
the women's liberation movement, but instead
of going back to dressing boys in the more
convenient dresses, many started dressing
their girls the same as boys- in pants.
Of course, today for many in the Western world,
girls wear pink dresses and boys wear blue
pants.
Period.
This curious phenomenon is so firmly entrenched
that if you tried to dress a two year old
boy in a pink dress, regardless of the child
perhaps having a traditionally male hair style
with male-centric accessories hinting that
your toddler is a boy, absolutely no one would
think they were looking at a male child until
you told them.
And when you did tell them, you're likely
to get some funny looks if not get eviscerated
if you posted a picture of it in modern social
media.
Humans are a funny bunch.
Bonus Fact:
• Through most of history, and still today
in many countries in Africa and Asia particularly,
the average age a child would be fully daytime
potty trained was typically around 18 months
old, instead of about double that today in
the Western world.
The change began to happen around the mid-20th
century thanks to the introduction of disposable
diapers and heavy marketing campaigns from
the manufacturers, which included widely promoted
(sponsored) so-called "scientific" studies
that showed that it was bad for the child
to potty train earlier (something still often
repeated today, even by some doctors, despite
a complete lack of evidence supporting such
a notion).
With the effort needed to potty train the
traditional way over waiting and the relative
ease and cleaner nature of disposable diapers
over having to wash cloth ones, people didn't
take much convincing to simply wait until
the child was much older and showed an active
interest in potty training.
However, recently with advancements in diaper
technology and pull-ups, this has started
to become more of a problem (mainly environmental,
but also sometimes financial) as kids show
interest in potty training later and later.
For reference, in 1957 in America, it was
typical to start potty training at 12 months
with the vast majority of children fully daytime
potty trained within 6-12 months of that and
nighttime potty trained by 3 years old.
Today, according to the American Academy of
Pediatrics, the average is to start potty
training at 24-25 months, achieving daytime
potty trained at 36 months and night time
around 5-6 years old.